looking for some thrills chills and
laughs to spice up the spooky season
netflix has the movie for you vampires
versus the bronx a netflix original
feature
has crept onto the streamer's top 10
list for movies in the us
the flick centers on a group of
youngsters from the titular new york
city borough who must repel an invasion
of the blood-sucking undead
we are going to wipe you out
like the vermin you are
the movie is winning over audiences and
critics alike thanks to the efforts of
its charming young cast
not to mention a smart funny screenplay
co-written by director osmani oz
rodriguez
a former staff writer for saturday night
live jaden michael who you may recognize
from his guest roles on blue bloods and
the netflix series the get down
leads the talented young cast of
vampires vs the bronx
joining him are gerald jones iii gregory
diaz iv
and imani lewis the film's adult cast
also includes clifford method man smith
who recently appeared in a recurring
role on the tracy morgan starring tbs
comedy series the last og
thomas pray also appearing are sarah
gadden
joel the kid marrow martinez and coco
jones
in vampires versus the bronx michael
stars as miguel martinez whose nickname
little mayor should tell you all you
need to know about his approach to life
in his diverse neighborhood he and his
buddies are regular patrons at their
beloved bodega which is suddenly
threatened by the incursion of several
new real estate developments around town
but miguel begins to notice that it's
not just the shops these businesses are
replacing that are vanishing
it's people too and some of the new
residents appearing in the area look
rather
transylvanian
[Music]
we got vampires in the bronx that's
right they're
actual vampires and of course miguel and
his pals have a tough time finding many
adults who will believe them
how will the kids keep their beloved
neighborhood from being overrun by
bloodsuckers and nine dollar espresso
shots
you'll just have to tune in to find out
just as netflix subscribers are flocking
to vampires versus the bronx
critics are heaping praise upon the film
in his review
ign's raphael motomayor commended
director rodriguez for utilizing quote
decades of existing tropes in order to
give voice to the voiceless
and tell a story that hasn't been told
before he also described vampires vs the
bronx as quote
a fun film with great sense of humor and
identity the perfect way to start the
halloween season
and a delightfully entertaining
kid-friendly horror film
other critics applauded the movie as
collectively charismatic
and an excellent example of a gen z
vampire film
but the flicks more than as felix
vasquez wrote for cinema crazed a quote
fun creepy and exciting halloween treat
it also deals with real and very heavy
topics
most notably gentrification yo check out
the courthouse
they're turning it into apartments y'all
know how this starts
then white people with canvas bags
that's always the first sign
rodriguez who was born in the dominican
republic explained in a recent interview
with now toronto that he was inspired
not only by
old-time monster movies but also by the
changing face of the washington heights
neighborhood in manhattan
which has traditionally housed a number
of dominican immigrants and their
families
rodriguez explained that the bronx as
one of the more traditionally diverse
bureaus
felt to him like quote the last frontier
as far as where gentrification will go
to be sure it's a highly relevant topic
many generations of immigrants have been
priced out of their neighborhoods by the
steady march of progress
over the decades and for many of the
areas that have managed to retain their
diversity in hometown feel
it's a constant struggle to keep outside
forces from taking over
it's an issue though that one wouldn't
exactly expect to be
explored by way of a fun hilarious
sometimes freaky film centered on
precocious tweens fighting vampires
that layer of topicality is just one of
the things that makes vampires versus
the bronx such an engaging watch
you can catch it on netflix right now
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one